et l'on termine avec le nouveau
spectacle du café de la gare à paris le
café de la gare c'est une institution
dans le monde du café théâtre
il ouvre sa saison avec un one man show
de benoît poelvoorde un acteur qui
s'était déjà fait remarquer dans un film
belge qui s'appelait c'est arrivé près
de chez vous et qui est devenu un film
culte
marie claire gauthier et jean marc garde
deux l'ont rencontré alors ça c'est un
des accesseurs du spectacle oui cette
machine que j'ai inventé pour rendre la
dignité aux hommes meurtris aux bornes
pour rendre la vie plus agréable aux
bornes
bon ça doit être miniaturisé pour le
cerveau vous vous en doutez
le premier passe de 14 29 ski
independent l'été le vilain héros du
film c'est arrivé près de chez vous et
passe le plus clair de son temps à
élever la provocation rang d'un art
majeur aujourd'hui au café de la gare
il est rené halte russe ultime rempart
de l'occident chrétien dans modèle
déposé la souffrance d'un homme qui
n'est pas reconnue dans ce qui fait
parce qu'ils travaillent pour aider ces
gens et malheureusement tout le monde
s'en fout personne ne prête attention à
tous à tous ces efforts et en plus sa
femme réussit mieux puisque est une
souffrance à transport pour les hommes à
notre époque
c'est le 10 mai
en fait ils sont trois compères a
concocté la cuisine humoristique du
spectacle linge ou l'autre met en scène
et le troisième a des idées
silence il ya dix ans qu'on travaille
ensemble sur des projets qui vont d'une
exposition pour les enfants un terrain
d'aventuré en passant par une pièce de
théâtre ou un film mais c'est vrai que
comme je le dis souvent on a un
imaginaire qui rebondit l'un sur celui
de l'autre etc et on pas d'une idée qui
est souvent tout embryonnaire et puis
c'est au fil des réunions en s'amusant
qu'on crée un spectacle savamment mis en
scène par deux jeunes réalisateurs et
quelques millions de pesos production
toutes les yeux de la tête
et tout ça pour la somme modique de 135